foreign
we've spent way too much time in the
last two decades in America talking
about our feelings we ought to deal with
some facts
and then let your feelings decide from
there how you feel about the facts but
let's let's start with facts because
that changes everything that leads me to
something I want to talk to you about
you've got your finger on the pulse of
this whole freaking job market that is
the weirdest job market I have ever seen
in 50 years oh yeah I've been working 50
years
short-cutting grass when I was 12. I'm
62. okay so but I mean I've been in the
workplace 40 years right and and I've
owned a business a lot of that time of
one kind or another and I've never seen
a job market this is the weirdest dadgum
job market on the one hand we've got
these immoral corporate
dupers laying people off just to run
their profits up or because they're
scared of what might happen next year
and anticipation of that they do ten
thousand people put them on the street
right there's that there's people
leaving their jobs
to go take higher pay or work from home
only to find out that they're the first
ones laid off or that they've entered
into a toxic culture of some kind or
another that's a dadgum mess and so for
ten thousand or Twenty or Thirty or
forty thousand dollars more a year that
they
you know they went and took a job and
now they regret it so there's the great
resignation followed by the great regret
you got those people you got the other
people being laid off and at the same
time we've still got a labor shortage
yes it's the most convoluted screwed up
thing I've ever seen well you got a fact
that you saw the pandemic create four
million new jobs okay and then
when the pandemic was over four million
people that had left or maybe were laid
off or retired during that time didn't
come back so that's created disparity
plus you've got seven million men that
are between the age of 25 and 55 who are
able to work and are choosing not to
work they are living off of someone
whether that be government benefits
we were talking about the other day said
they spent 2 000 hours a year on a
screen which means they're getting like
Call of Duty and they don't know what
duty is that's right they're they're
medicating themselves with the dopamine
from screens and entertainment in all of
its various forms and instead of getting
out there and getting the contribution
and the dopamine that comes from hey I
did something that mattered today so we
have a work ethic crisis we have a
shortage of Labor that's right we have a
values crisis with corporate America
dumping people on the street uh we have
people jumping ship from the you know
out of The Frying Pan Into the Fire they
leave what they thought was a bad job to
get a much better pay but at a horrible
Place who treats them like crap so I can
work from home part-time and get paid
for full-time because everybody that
works from home does not work eight
hours let me just tell you okay you sit
on your butt we know what you're doing
and or you're working two of these
full-time jobs which is straight up
unethical that's professional polygamy
Dave I coined that term the other day
professional police working two
full-time jobs and calling it work from
home yeah it's it you're cheating on
both of them
professional polygamy you get quiet
quitting I decided to come up with my
own term but it's a real thing you're
lying to both companies it's uh it's
career infidelity that's it oh my God I
know I know okay no but so here's what's
interesting and and I want to give an
economic and a money play on this all of
that that we just like in the middle of
that a person that will work hard and
has character in the middle of all that
discombobulation there's opportunity big
time oh sure of course there is well but
see now here's what's interesting but
you got to be careful not to just take
the paycheck opportunity it's not just a
paycheck I'm saying you could go find a
great company at above average pay oh
yeah and move up and and have a great
career opportunity without without
working for some bunch of dubers that's
right and
um but people don't make the decision
exclusively on the pay change no no
you've got to look at the quality of the
leadership team the situation yeah so
it's the right role because the data is
telling us if you're working from home
or if you're the last one one hired
you're going to be the first ones laid
off absolutely true that is database so
you are vulnerable if you took a job
doing that for more so you left a
regular job in the office 40 hours
making and you make 35 000 a year more
than you used to make but you're working
from home uh you may be your head's the
first one on the Block and here's
another fact that remote workers may be
the first to go is they ship jobs
overseas they could pay you from home
they could pay somebody from another
country from home